ah yes I don't want to read it I'm a
hustler and I do hustler stuff
I can't they're not all works of Arts I
don't know what to tell you sir I can't
be proud of everything I've ever said
ever on Facebook so Quinta Brunson is
hoping her teacher will understand that
Barack won last night and that's why I
don't have a safer way to go past Quinta
may ck is you know you love me xoxo
which is the Gossip Girl Kate Reynolds
is facebooking at work who I hope no one
catches me it's [ __ ] at work dude your
vomit won't come off my driveway haha I
threw up on his driveway
I'm guessing and I have no recollection
of it because I was probably like that
it's like right after I started college
love in Malibu in the Pepperdine life
one exclamation point then like a month
later September 4 2007 over the fact
that she's in college
dot dot already is it a week ah
embarrassing well it's been 15 years but
I finally dislocated my knee dancing
again hashtag too funky for my own good
I just danced too hard when I get to
dancing if I haven't been stretching
Harold Han has intentionally smelled a
dead rabbit today it smelled kind of
sweet perfect stage of rot question mark
oh I don't know what this means
yeah November 19th 2006 a big ugly nerd
I don't know what this means there's a
record of who you are just internally
but also who you are presenting yourself
to be for some reason it's like more
embarrassing to look at yourself be
weird when you were younger but there's
like no doubt that this video will be
embarrassing to me probably when I'm 30
this cannot know